[Music]
on this friday night macabre discovery
my reason the world has to acknowledge
this is a genocide of the ukrainian
people the hundreds of unmarked graves
found in a city reclaimed from russian
forces heartfelt messages for her
majesty i'm quite good at expressing my
feelings through
writing and the ever extending line to
see her one last time asylum seekers say
they're being duped and dumped the
intensifying border battle with migrants
caught in the middle
and hitting a royal high note
some of the musicians behind
performances fit for kings and queens
[Music]
global national with farah nasser
reporting tonight from london
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us we're here in london overlooking
westminster abbey where the queen's
funeral will take place on monday we
have extensive world coverage in just a
moment but we want to begin tonight with
the situation in ukraine an
investigation is underway into a
disturbing discovery ukrainian
authorities have found hundreds of
graves in an area recently retaken from
russia the mass burial site is in a
forest just outside of izum a city about
120 kilometers southeast of kharkiv izum
was invaded in the early days of the war
and used by russia as a key military hub
now ukraine believes the site could be
the largest mass grave uncovered in the
war so far eric sorenson has more on the
discovery and what it could mean for the
conflict and a warning this story does
contain some disturbing images
it is a sickening discovery every bit as
gruesome as feared well over 400 bodies
have now been discovered in graves in
the woods of israel a region hastily
abandoned by russian forces just days
ago
this man recalls finding a family of
seven killed in their home and now
likely buried here investigators are
looking for clues as to how each person
died some with hands tied behind their
backs some are children well done
the aim is to get the facts says this
ukrainian war crimes prosecutor the
world has to acknowledge that this is a
genocide of the ukrainian people
on the day the united nations marks as
the international day of peace the u.n
says it's sending investigators to isium
to examine the bodies that have been
found
our investigators will work with
international ones says ukraine's
president vladimir zelinski
in israel he says 450 bodies were found
buried some tortured
the discovery comes just as russia's
vladimir putin is being confronted
publicly at a summit of loosely allied
nations in uzbekistan
india's prime minister narendra modi
told putin today's era is not a war era
i have told you on the phone about this
putin acknowledged the concerns you
constantly expressed and said he wants
to stop the conflict as soon as possible
but says ukraine has rejected talks a
day earlier putin met with china's
president xi jinping and said the
chinese leader expressed his concerns
right now putin appears to have few
friends and fewer options putin doesn't
have any good options his best option is
to push for negotiations it buys him
time it allows russian forces to regroup
looking
the grizzly task of finding bodies
carries on
we have found video of the burial here
says ole kotenko a missing persons
officer
a sign says there are 17 bodies we will
count them he says
there is still much to uncover the
russians are gone but ukraine's
president says they left behind death
everywhere
eric sorenson global news
moscow's global isolation continues to
be felt and the latest blow is coming
from buckingham palace who omitted
vladimir putin from the invite list to
queen elizabeth's state funeral but a
key ukrainian figure has reportedly been
invited and that is first lady olenna
zelenska she's said to be joining dozens
of other world leaders here in london on
monday to represent ukraine according to
britain's the sun newspaper zelenska
will attend the reception hosted by king
charles the day before the funeral and
then fly back to ukraine as soon as the
ceremony ends
the vigil capped off a day of heavy
emotions in the british capital as the
nation prepares for a state funeral
unlike any other scene before our europe
bureau chief crystal commansing joins us
now and crystal you're near westminster
hall right now where people exit after
paying respects to the queen
yeah far people are filing pass right
now they've had the opportunity to file
past the queen's coffin as it lies in
state now these people have waited about
11 hours on average the people in line
right now still waiting to make their
way into westminster hall are being told
it will be a very long and cold night in
the queue we should mention the
accessible queue has been shut down all
the spaces have been allotted and it
won't reopen until midday saturday but
of course this isn't the only cue
thousands were also waiting in line to
file past and lay flowers at the floral
tribute in nearby green park
they're calm and carrying on but with
heavy hearts the emotional load
palatial i say farewell at 96 my mind my
soul i feel them slip but i do not worry
i do not fear my family my children are
surrounding me here as i drift from one
reality to another i begin to soon
discover my beloved philip so strong and
proud
i'm
not really good at expressing my
feelings but i'm quite good at
expressing my feelings through
writing and i write it because
i was really upset when the queen died
many are putting pen to paper sharing
both their grief and memories of queen
elizabeth ii
rows and rows of tributes are being
placed with great care and diligently
observed
many still hoping to pay their respects
friday afternoon were jolted it's been
closed until further notice the cue
reached capacity people were told to
leave and watch for updates but no one
moved no idea what this is all about now
we've come a long way today all of us
haven't we so uh all different parts of
the country so we're you know we need to
pay our respects to the creek
the shutdown only lasted a few hours but
mourners were told they might not reach
westminster for 24 hours the bbc reports
it will likely be the largest single
ceremonial event staged in britain since
the second world war
just walking through this really put
into perspective how the the globe has
been impacted by this
i'm calm at peace no need to be sad the
freedom of this makes me glad i no
longer hurt or feel this pain so goodbye
britain until we meet again
twelve-year-old ava telling me that she
feels like she's lost her grandmother
meanwhile the royal grandchildren will
be holding a vigil at the corners of
their grandmother's coffin tomorrow just
as their parents did today now the eight
grandchildren it's not known if they'll
take two different shifts their parents
were there for about 15 minutes and we
can also say farah that the duke of
sussex prince harry will be in his royal
dress his story his military dress
tomorrow as the royal grandchildren hold
vigil in front of the coffin
crystal command singh on the streets of
london for us tonight thank you crystal
before tonight's vigil at westminster
hall king charles was in wales for his
first visit as the new monarch
a ceremonial 21 gun salute welcomed the
king and wife camilla the queen consort
to cardiff the royal couple greeted
crowds before the king addressed members
of the welsh parliament saying
it had been a privilege to serve as
prince of wales for more than 60 years
the trip marked the last of the king's
visits to the uk's four nations as the
new monarch
the new prince and princess of wales
meanwhile were at an army training
center just outside of london to meet
with commonwealth troops who traveled to
the uk for the queen's state funeral
among them are nearly 100 canadian armed
forces personnel who are said to be
taking part in monday's ceremony along
with a contingent from the rcmp
and a high profile group of canadians
landed in london today ahead of the
queen's funeral on monday among them
dignitaries a celebrity and an olympian
our abigail beeman is traveling with the
contingent and joins us now with how the
next few days are expected to unfold
abigail
about 2 000 people are expected to be
inside westminster abbey for the funeral
the canadian delegation numbers 19 about
half of them traveling together to
london
joining prime minister justin trudeau on
this trip his wife sophie the governor
general mary simon and her husband as
well as four former prime ministers and
two former governors general other
canadians making up the 19 members of
the group are three indigenous leaders
including assembly of first nations
national chief roseanne archibald as
well as actress sandra oh and olympian
mark tewksbury ahead of the queen's
funeral monday we're expecting the prime
minister to have his first audience with
now king charles iii as well as a
bilateral meeting with the new uk prime
minister liz truss it was the queen's
wish to have a representation of
canadians present the same is true for
other commonwealth nations and their
delegations farah
abigail beam in ottawa at ottawa
international airport thank you abigail
to stay together or break up coming up
how canadians are feeling about
preserving ties with the british
monarchy plus why the white house says
republicans are using migrants as
political pawns
in the u.s humanitarian groups have
condemned what they've called political
stunts part of a republican campaign to
reignite the debate over illegal border
crossings this week dozens of migrants
boarded planes and buses to wealthy
democratic strongholds many migrants say
they were duped and dumped as jackson
prosko reports their relocations were
organized by texas and florida's
republican governors who claimed they
were just trying to make a point about a
so-called immigration crisis on their
doorstep along america's southern border
far from the southern border the resort
island of martha's vineyard is now at
the center of the u.s immigration crisis
50 venezuelan asylum seekers including
young children were sent here without
warning
they told me there was a work
opportunity he says we were going to a
city but we ended up staying here
none speak english or have family nearby
they say they were tricked into boarding
planes in texas
jets chartered by florida's republican
governor ron desantis they were promised
jobs and they were promised immigration
papers the republican governor of texas
has used the same tactics this week
bussing more than 100 migrants to the
washington home of the vice president
without food or proper clothing what
they're doing is simply wrong it's
un-american it's reckless so far this
year more than 13 thousand asylum
seekers have been sent from southern
states to washington chicago and new
york shelters are nearing the breaking
point we are not a sanctuary state and
it's better to be able to go to a
sanctuary jurisdiction and yes we will
help facilitate that transport for you
opponents accuse the governors of using
vulnerable refugees as political pawns
there are calls for the justice
department to investigate possible
violations of federal law we are also
oppressed in our countries and we don't
come here
to be oppressed again
to be trafficked again
with no end in sight of the humanitarian
crisis and with midterm elections
looming the governors say they won't
stop shipping asylum seekers across the
country until there are reforms at the
border
jackson prosko global news washington
says it's prepared for retaliation from
russia after it placed a russian owned
refinery under federal control germany
says the decision was made to protect
the country and to ensure energy
supplies continue given russia has
threatened to turn off the taps to
europe
eu sanctions placed on russia over its
invasion of ukraine have created an
energy crisis the refinery supplies
berlin with 90 percent of its fuel
germany is in talks to get supplies from
other countries like poland and
kazakhstan if russia decides to stop
exports
at least nine people are dead after
torrential overnight rains and flash
flooding hit central italy
around 40 centimeters of rain fell
within two to three hours which is a
third of the usual amount seen all year
hundreds of firefighters are currently
helping in the area and have rescued
dozens of people who climbed onto roofs
and up trees to escape the water
and in central china a fire tore through
a 42-story skyscraper sending flaming
debris raining down on the streets
it broke out inside the office tower
housing the country's biggest telecom
operator where 35 tons of fuel for
servers were stored dozens of floors
burned in just 20 minutes and people
working inside were seen escaping the
flames no deaths have been reported
firefighters put the fire out within
about half an hour
ahead could canada cut off the kink the
debates about royal ties and whether the
queen's death could cause the
commonwealth to crack and spur a
republic
[Music]
you're watching global national
[Music]
the canadian flag as we know it is
iconic but choosing a distinct design
devoid of the british union jack led to
heated debate in the 60s a similar
debate is happening now regarding king
charles iii's role as canada's head of
state
new polling from ipsos found that 54 of
canadians agree it's time to end formal
ties with the monarchy however a deeper
dive into the numbers sees only 20
percent strongly agree far short of the
unanimity needed to make it happen
michael a has more on an argument that
has canadians feeling conflicted
queen elizabeth's deep connection to
canada was on display every time she
rode her favorite horse burma had been
gifted to her by the rcmp in 1969.
within canada her image was everywhere
from canadian currency to the portraits
hung in arenas well new polling from
ipsos confirms the depths of her
relationship with canada 82 of canadians
were happy with how she conducted
herself as monarch although her heir
king charles iii clearly has his work
cut out for him in the eyes of canadians
it proves that what we've known for a
long time that it was the queen who was
holding the monarchy together
when it comes to favorability numbers
king charles and queen consort camilla
are low and their lack of popularity has
in part reopened the discussion about
the king's role as canada's head of
state even if the survey does show
canadians don't strongly agree one way
or the other the only thing that's been
keeping us a monarchy aside from
obviously the popularity of the queen is
apathy
and as long as people don't care
and aren't interested then we'll
continue to be a monarchy well people
care but the question is how much when
weighing the pros and cons canadians see
the monarchy as something that helps
define our identity while helping to
keep us distinct from the us but flip
the coin and canadians see the royals as
nothing more than celebrities with
uncomfortable ties to colonialism you
have to say to yourself okay
if we're going to do away with the
monarchy what are we going to replace it
with and while canadians are clearly
conflicted former lieutenant governor of
ontario david only says the
constitutional requirement to have the
house of commons senate in all 10
provinces unanimously consent to sever
ties makes it a long shot when you think
of the problems facing canada that we
have today
where does the priority fit for
you know ending our relationship with
the monarchy
is it in the top 10 the top 20. i think
that's a companion
survey i'd like to see
where does it fit it might not be a
pressing issue but it's one that won't
go away mike drolite global news toronto
and the funeral for the queen is on
monday at westminster abbey just behind
me and we're going to have live coverage
starting at 5 a.m eastern 2 a.m pacific
here on global television globalnews.com
and on our other streaming platforms
next music fit for a king meet the
dedicated musicians who play for the
royal family
[Music]
[Applause]
the queen like her son king charles was
a music buff and her interests spanned
genres from classical to beg pipes many
mornings she woke up to the sound of a
piper
musicians played almost everywhere the
queen went but as for what it's like to
play for royalty well jeff semple found
out
[Music]
claire jones is practicing for a
performance that's fit for a king
[Music]
the welsh musician first struck a chord
with the royal family back in 2007
chosen to become prince charles's
official harpist a centuries-old
position discontinued after queen
victoria but resurrected by charles king
charles has always been an advocate for
the arts over four years she performed
at 180 royal engagements leading
orchestras playing solo for 75 000 in a
rugby stadium and serenading will and
kate's royal wedding reception i
relished every opportunity and loved
every second
one of her most memorable moments was
performing alone just for the queen she
asked me about the role uh wanted to
know more about the harp the royal harp
i was playing at the time it was such a
surreal moment to do that because i
think people prepared so much to play
for royalty and of course having a
chance to do it with just her
in the room was pretty incredible
music has long played an enormous role
in royal ceremonies and monday's funeral
will be no different some of the last
musicians to ever perform for the queen
were actually canadian
in august this ottawa pipe and drum
troop was invited to perform at balmoral
castle the queen is known for her love
of bagpipes and the canadians also had
corgis you want to do a really good job
so maybe you stand up a bit straighter
and you're just doing your very very
best this pipe major performed for her
majesty on five occasions last month she
says the queen seemed in great spirits
she never imagined this performance
would be the last i'm just delighted
that she was so gracious to invite us
you know and give us that opportunity
it's very difficult i think for us in
britain to imagine a future really
without the queen being there jones left
the palace in 2011 but after the queen's
death she and her composer husband were
asked to write a new song
[Music]
to welcome charles to wales for the
first time as king slightly on the
zombie side because we have to remember
he's only become the king because of the
passing of our queen but um it's a rite
of passage isn't it it's the
inevitability of our of our tradition uh
here in the uk
making music to match the moment a
soundtrack for history
jeff semple global news cardiff
[Music]
the queen loved her music and we all
know she loved her tea too earl grey to
be specific piping hot with a splash of
milk well today in her honor some
elementary students in saskatoon got to
enjoy their own version of high tea
complete with biscuits and vintage cups
that's global national for this friday
thank you for spending part of your
evening with us until tomorrow take care
of yourselves and each other good night
from london
[Music]